en tant qu'avocat m ouimette vous êtes
l'avocat quand un avocat vient de dire
ça il veut pas qu'on dénonce quelque
chose ouais alors moi je pourrait
émettre quelques doutes sur le fait que
l'avocat soit venu comme ça vous le dire
mais ça c'est moi dire parce que je
connais comme un peu les procédures dire
le prévenu j'ai vécu six mois date à
temps parce que je voyais que toi juste
un truc c'est que six mois il ya un
avocat qui s'approche de mon client sans
avoir parlé d'abord finir ça peut mal se
finir parce que il viole toutes les
règles déontologiques donc déjà il ya un
problème il ya un problème d'emblée
c'est que l'histoire là tout à coup moi
je n'ai pas d'avis mais sur ce point là
bon tu avais jamais là j'ai un problème
de crédibilité qu l'histoire tu as vécu
c'est pas avec une histoire mais je vis
les procès tous les jours mais non mais
t'as tes procès il ya eu bon procès
fatigués ce que tu as à
prêter procès je suis
dans ma salle est ce que tu sais comment
ça s'est passé ça a été enregistrée ce
que tu sais comment ça s'est passé est
enregistrée non pas le procès et
enregistrer les gens enregistré quand il
m'a dit ça l'avocat mais la seule
différence quand je les dis parce que
moi j'étais je dis ok je m'arrange avec
toi après j'ai été au tribunal j'aurais
dit l'avocat m'a proposé à 1 euro si je
parlais pas donc je voulais dire au
tribunal comme toi qui as d'état qui est
là dedans comme quoi qu'à la caisse de
dépôt qu'est la danse et mets la seule
différence la seule différence je suis
la seule victime peut-être que je suis
là c'est en vie la victime non non non
non on va se mettre d'accord si eu un
procès et une condamnation donc la
victime c'est pas toi le coupable c'est
toi on va pas confondre du à charge et
moi je connais pas ton histoire en tant
que tel mais on peut pas ici devant des
millions de spectateurs dire que quand
tu te fais condamné par la justice c'est
toi la victime attention quand même il y
avait juste à temps
à parler il était victime de lui-même
mais pas du tout
ça vaut on affaire à vos quatre ans j'ai
pris 8 ans ouais non mais il ya un autre
paramètre 1 mais quels paramètres
d'un truc c'est que moi ce qui me
perturbe dans ton histoire c'est que je
connais un peu les procédures la caisse
des dépôts et consignations que moi j'ai
eu dans quelques dossiers d'ailleurs
venir qu'est ce qu'elle fait en général
elle conclu non avant l'audience à la
balance des conclusions de partie civile
la tarik est une série américaine ton
truc quoi
tu m'as danse pas je te file un euro ça
c'est sympa à télé tu veux mais dans la
vraie vie c'est pas comme ça que ça se
passe aux audiences se dit raymond
l'avocat qui vient qui te parle à toi et
pas aux confrères et rebonds si tu veux
m désolé mais tu pètes si dans ton monde
que ça se passe comme ça madame
dans le mien ça se passe comme ça y est
studieuse quand tu parles de 24
milliards c'est pas ton monde non mais
non mais c'est pas ton nom est des peaux
noires si ça peut pas être tombée la
médecine entend parler de 3000 tu peux
te connais tu sais maman c'est quoi ce
shift oublié un truc c'est que j'ai
oubliées ou 240 milliards la justice
reste la même des règles soir là même
mais pour toi res alors pourquoi j'ai
pris 8 ans mais j'ai pris 8 ans tu peux
faire ce que tu as en quatre ans
pourquoi tabac en quatre ans mais
pourquoi parce que ça a été la caisse
des poneys considère années s'avoue pas
car là tu accuses l'état de cette servi
aussi dans cette amère je vais
t'expliquer que chez moi j'ai payé dans
cette affaire donc je parle j'en ai
marre a contacté et fiche je veux parler
ce soir
j'arrête c'est lui la tâche et non
j'arrête chez vous non mais non quand
c'est pas moi pas tu as raison c'est
pour toi en cas raison tu as raison on a
autant de passion et la raison de
cervelle et mon ami c'est non parce
qu'ils ont fait 1 2 on vient de me le
dire voilà non mais t'as une oreillette
la même que yakin
non mais à taille oreillettes divine pas
d'accord
non mais c'est vrai je veux pas que park
odile des bêtises qu'elle lui porte
préjudice derrière que c'est quand même
un ami non c'est pas préjudice et parce
que j'en ai marre que les gens donnent
des conseils ou pas ou font payer les
conseils qu'ils ont à vue ils ont rien à
voir
j'évite tout
dire le ça veut dire que moi que j'ai
vécu l'histoire est-ce que franchement
est ce que vous y croyez que j'ai volé
300 euros oui mais non mais non mais ce
que vous à moi vous pas oui croyez ça
arriverait pourquoi vous croyez le
négatif et positif ça veut dire vous
croyez pas le reste faut croire le reste
il ya un ensemble il ya une histoire y
en a qui font l'histoire y en a qui la
raconte vous vous la raconter à votre
manière